so Donald Trump or radically abandoned the
NATO summit early yesterday and flew back
to the United States after being ridiculed
on camera by a number of world leaders.
We already talked about that yesterday.
I told you several world leaders were caught
on camera making fun of the American president,
Donald Trump.
It was Canadian prime minister Justin Trudeau,
the French president, Emmanuel McCrone and
Trump, Ian British prime minister Boris Johnson.
Quick reminder of that video,
so
the literal laughingstock among world leaders,
it's not surprising, it's not new if you've
been paying attention.
So we knew the reaction would be furious from
Trump, and indeed he was furious.
Throwing a tantrum.
Then calling Justin Trudeau two faced, which
we'll talk about shortly, and then cutting
short his entire trip to the NATO summit and
flying back to the United States.
Trump was scheduled yesterday to do a press
conference at three 30 in the afternoon, local
time, canceled it and came back to the United
States.
When you elect the clown, you get a circus.
Trump of course, tweeting as if everything
is totally fine, claiming another major victory
in the world of bigly winning, tweeting, just
finished meetings with Turkey and Germany,
heading to a meeting now with those countries
that have met their 2% goals, followed by
meetings with Denmark and Italy.
When today's meetings are over, I will be
heading back to Washington.
We won't be doing a press conference at the
close of NATO because we did so many over
the past two days.
Safe travels to all.
Um, of course.
Why would you eat this is like when he said
he got on the phone with Sunland and demanded
absolutely no quid pro quo.
It's like, why are we even talking about a
quid pro quo?
It's like if I call someone and say, I really
need you to pick up my wife, but definitely
don't kill her.
Okay, I'm telling you, do not kill her.
Why are we even talking about that much the
same way?
Why is Trump even talking about the fact that
he's not doing a press conference?
He clearly is very triggered over, listen
in the end, wasn't it just locker room talk
of sorts that those world leaders were engaging
in.
I am just so sick of being a constant embarrassment
around the world by having this man in the
white house because the office of the presidency
has never been more devalued.
The trade war is a joke.
Trump's positions on NATO are a joke.
It's all a joke.
And yet I dare say 60 million, 62 million,
at least 55 million people are going to vote
for this for another four years of this in
just 11 months.
That's the scariest part of all of it.
And consider how fragile the president is.
I, um, listen to a really interesting interview.
Yesterday, Hillary Clinton appeared on the
Howard stern show yesterday.
Might sound like a weird conversation.
It was absolutely fantastic.
I would encourage you to try to find it.
If you're a serious XM subscriber.
I think you can just see it, find it on demand
on the app.
Uh, but otherwise maybe it's floating around
and she very astutely talked about how she
had to sort of measure her reactions.
One example that was given was, don't know
if you remember the debates back in 2016 between
Trump and Hillary, but there would be moments
where Trump would start sort of stocking in
the background and kind of standing close
to Hillary Clinton.
And she didn't react to it.
And in the, uh, conversation with Howard stern
yesterday, she actually said, I knew if I
turned around and said, Hey, back off or whatever
the headlines would be, she's on hinge, she's
going crazy.
She can't handle Trump.
How will she be able to handle Putin or whatever?
Consider the fragility and trigger ability
of Donald Trump.
He mocks women, people with disabilities,
foreign leaders, members of the military,
including for the fact that they were held
as prisoners of war, political opponents.
He comes up with nicknames for everybody.
Uh, and then just because someone was critical
of him, he leaves the NATO summit early calls
Justin Trudeau two faced and then crafts a
narrative that really he want everything and
he's taking his seven 47 and flying home.
Did Barack Obama ever do this policy differences
aside?
Can anyone imagine Hillary Clinton ever behaving
in this way?
It's pathetic to a huge degree, but we've
become desensitized.
We, I said it yesterday, I think, or the day
before, as much as I try not to allow this
to happen, I recognize that a lot of this
insanity has become normalized because it's
been going on for three years at this point
or however long it's been.
Almost three years.
Yes, almost three years.
Um, we need to make sure, not only that, we
don't let the normalization, um, uh, sort
of creep in as it has even for me, but we
also are going to have to work really, really
hard once this nightmare is over.
Once the the, the mango menace has gone to
get back to the type of political discourse,
which wasn't any, any beauty by the way, it
had already been degraded significantly.
But to get back to the political discourse
that existed before Donald Trump and then
ideally we could go back even further, although
that will be a much more uphill battle to
climb.
Let's now talk about Trump self congratulating
on a hot mic.